PEOPLE.
ALL RIGHT.
SARA, THANK YOU FOR THE REPORT.
HERE NOW WITH MORE REACTION IS
THE SENATOR FROM THE GREAT STATE
OF SOUTH CAROLINA, LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
SENATOR, I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU EARLIER TODAY.
YOU BELIEVE THEY WERE TRYING TO
KILL AMERICANS.
TELL US WHY YOU BELIEVE THAT?
>> A 3RD GRADER CAN FIGURE THIS
OUT.
THEY ARE OVER RIDING THE
EMBASSY.
THEY KILLED A CONTRACTOR.
SOLEIMANI HAS BEEN KILLING
AMERICANS WERE 20 YEARS.
HE'S ON THE GROUND IN BAGHDAD.
SEAN:  THEY MISSED THEIR
TARGET.
>> I'M SORRY.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE TALKING ON IF
WE HAD GOOD INTEL ON SOLEIMANI.
HE WAS UP TO NO GOOD.
HE WAS PLANNING AN ATTACK.
I ALWAYS BELIEVED THEY WERE
TRYING TO KILL AMERICANS.
IF YOU LAUNCH MISSILES INSIDE AN
AIR BASE, KILL PEOPLE.
WE MOVED OUR PEOPLE OUT.
WE HAD FOUR-HOUR'S NOTICE.
I THINK IT IS MORE FORTUNE THAN
LACK OF INTENT.
THE PRESIDENT MADE A VERY BOLD
DECISION TODAY TO ALLOWS THINGS
TO CALM DOWN.
THIS SPEAK WILL BE TALKED ABOUT
LONG AFTER HIS SECOND TERM.
THIS IS RESETTING THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE WORLD
IN IRAN JUST NOT THE UNITED
STATES.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THERE'S AN
EVIL EMPIRE IN IRAN THAT'S BEEN
DESTROYING THE WORLD AND KILLING
THE PEOPLE IN ISRAEL AND COMING
AFTER US.
I WILL NO LONGER TOLERATE IT.
THIS IS ON PAR WITH REAGAN'S
TEAR DOWN THE THE WALL SPEECH.
>> THERE'S A DAY OF RECKONING.
A SQUARED, B SQUARED, C
SQUARED.
RADICALISM WITH NUCLEAR WEAPONS
EQUALS THE POTENTIAL FOR A
MODERN-DAY HOLOCAUST.
WE CAN'T EVER LET THAT HAPPEN.
LET'S ASSUME IRANIANS CLING TO
THEIR SICK AND EVIL IDEOLOGY.
THE WORLD HAS A DAY OF
RECKONING.
INTELLIGENCE IS GETTING CLOSE.
IT HAS TO GO.
>> THERE'S THE CONFLICT WITH
IRAN THAT WILL BE CHOOSING THE
CONFLICT.
THE PRESIDENT GAVE THEM AN OUT.
CHANGE YOUR BEHAVIOR.
STOP BEING THE LARGEST STATE
SPONSOR OF TERRORISM.
THAT'S NOT TOO MUCH TO ASK.
STAND DOWN YOUR MISSILE
PROGRAM.
YOU CAN HAVE A NUCLEAR POWER
PROGRAM, BUT NOT A PATHWAY TO A
BOMB.
THAT'S THE THREE CONDITIONS THAT
THE PRESIDENT HAS LAID DOWN.
THEY CAN MEET THE CONDITIONS IF
THEY WANT TO.
IF THEY CHOOSE TO DEFY PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND CHOOSE TO TRY TO GET A
NUCLEAR WEAPON AND HAVE A
NUCLEAR BREAKOUT AND IF THEY
CHOOSE TO CONTINUE TO TRY TO
KILL AMERICANS IN THE FUTURE,
THEY ARE BASICALLY WRITING THEIR
OWN DEATH WARRANT.
HE WILL DESTROY THEIR ECONOMY.
THE REGIME WILL COME TO A FIERY
END IF THEY DO NOT MEET THE
CONDITIONS SET OUT BY PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
SEAN:  I HAPPEN TO LIKE RAND
PAUL AND SENATOR MIKE LEE.
I DON'T AGREE WITH THEM ON THE
WAR POWERS ACT INTERPRETATION.
THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF HAS THE
RIGHT TO DEFEND THE COUNTRY AND
NOT IMMEDIATELY GO TO CONGRESS.
YOU WENT AS FAR TO SAY THEY ARE
EMPOWERING THE ENEMY WITH THOSE
ARGUMENTS.
WHY WOULD THEY WANT TO TIE THE
HANDS OF OUR COMMANDER IN
CHIEF?
WE HAVE AN COMMUNITY HERE TO
TAKE OUT SOLEIMANI.
RELATE ME ASK NANCY PELOSI
FIRST?
>> THEY ARE GREAT PATRIOTS.
YOU CAN'T HAVE 535 WAR POWER IN
CHIEFS.
THERE'S ONLY ONE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF.
IF YOU DON'T TAKE THE ACTION
THEY ARE TAKING, AS CONGRESS,
YOU CAN DEFUND THOSE ACTIONS.
WE HAVE CONTROL OVER THE POWER.
THEY ARE GREAT AMERICANS.
WHEN WE GET ON THE FLOOR OF THE
UNITED STATES SENATE IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF WEEKS AND TALKING
ABOUT RESTRICTING THE ABILITY TO
DEAL WITH THE RELIGIOUS PIECE IN
IRAN, IT WILL BE SCENE AS THE
DIVISION AS HOME.
I CAN'T IMAGINE SINCE WORLD WAR
II.
THERE'S A PLAN.
YOU ARE NOT IN IT.
WHEN HE SAYS I WANT TO KILL AND
DESTROY ISRAEL, HE'S NOT
KILLING.
HE'S TRYING TO PURIFY THE
FAITH.
IN YOUR EYES, AFTER 40 YEARS OF
TERROR AND U.S. FIGURES THIS
OUT, THEY ARE NOT LOOKING VERY
HARD.
SEAN:  YOU AND I ARE IN FULL
AGREEMENT.
IT CAN'T BE.
LAST QUESTION YOU ARE NOW
PUSHING FOR YOUR RESOLUTION IN
THE SENATE AS IT DEALS WITH
NANCY PELOSI.
>> RIGHT.
I BELIEVE THAT SHE CAN DICTATE
TO THE UNITED STATES SENATE
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
THE PELOSI IMPEACHMENT DAMN HAS
BROKEN.
WE'VE HAD FIVE DEMOCRATS SAY
SEND OVER THE ARTICLES.
IF YOU BELIEVE IT TO BE URGENT,
SEND IT.
SHE'S LOSING DEMOCRATS.
THE IMPEACHMENT DAMN OF NANCY
PELOSI IS ABOUT TO RACK.
SEAN:  SENATOR, THANK YOU.